alexéi navalni a abogado de formación ha
denunciado desde hace más de diez años
en su blog y en twitter la corrupción de
las élites de rusia apodado por la
revista time como el erin brockovich
ruso recurrentemente llama a
manifestaciones contra el poder en
varias ocasiones navalny ha acusado a
vladimir putin de haber creado un
partido de estafadores y de ladrones a
veces hasta poner su seguridad en
peligro
lo que se sospecha hacer un último
intento en contra de su salud no es una
novedad para alexéi navalni el líder de
opinión ya había sido hospitalizado
varias veces por supuestos
envenenamientos en 2017 les parecieron
un desinfectante cuando salía de su
despacho en moscú en 2019 mientras
estaba en la cárcel afirmó haber sido
envenenado fue hospitalizado pero las
autoridades aseguran que fue una simple
reacción alérgica ese mismo año
fue condenado a pagar 14 millones de
dólares por difamación y sus oficinas
fueron registradas políticamente álex
cenaban y tiene una gran proyección en
diciembre de 2016 anunciaba su
candidatura a las elecciones
presidenciales rusas del 2018 justo un
año después en diciembre del 2017 la
comisión electoral estipulaba que no
podía presentarse a las urnas por
sospechas de corrupción
desde entonces llamó durante varios
meses a manifestaciones a través del
país tras este nuevo episodio de
presunto envenenamiento
el presidente francés emmanuel manjón
ofreció alexéi navalni asilo político
entre tanto y aún en estado de coma
llegó a berlín la capital alemana para
recibir tratamiento médico